the most upsetting bits of information
in this reflections issued to me in fact
I was so disturbed by it even though I
sort of knew the not the dimension how
bad it was I had to just get up and walk
around I couldn't do anything else and
that was an article about our giving we
do give more in dollars i believe than
anyone else in the world than any other
country in the world but that we give a
very small percentage compared to other
countries and what bothered me even more
is how little American Christians give
the median Christian giver in this
country gives now how much do you think
I mean I was taught that should be ten
percent or now we'd say any percent but
a percent not just if I have some left
over the median Christian giver
contributes point six two percent about
half of a percent of income I suspect
that the Jewish population and the
Muslim population a more generous since
it is a pillar of of Islam and it is
also that our Jewish friends are very
very known to be generous and I I don't
know what we in leadership in the
Christian tradition need to do about it
but I am quite horrified as I hope you
are too now that I've sort of dropped
that little bomb with the rest of you
like to say I think it seems to me that
some of these themes come together
because I think today I certainly
believe that geography is important and
it expands from our own self but
particularly with social media and
television I think people do link with
the struggles that are going on I can
tell you that my kids at the breakfast
table get up in the morning and they say
is Qaddafi still there so there is an
awareness of what's going on we have
staff on the ground in Egypt and
and Tunisia and Libya and they're
interacting and but they're also you
know blogging they're tweeting facebook
so that I think that you know and we
certainly know the role that the Google
guy in the Egypt so that this whole
world is so interconnected today and
it's certainly connected in terms of
philanthropy and resources you know I
think so you're giving us an encouraging
word is that I think that it's a little
bit like the I think it's the comparable
the mastered see that's important
yesterday we received a
twenty-five-thousand-dollar grant from
Los Angeles not known as the center of
philanthropy while the center of
activism from an indian-american
individual came out of the blue it's you
know it will not only sustain it will
develop our program and lead to we
believe some additional larger scale
government assistance a two major forms
of participating in development one is
private philanthropy and there's a
plenty of good groups here today that
are active in that area and the other is
government philanthropy if I can use
that word development assistance and the
two need to go together I think we do
need to be challenged i think we
certainly need to be doing better in
both scales both on the private side and
on the governmental side well certainly
we need a partnership and those who
think just one or the other is the
answer i think all of us in this room
would object to that Katherine did you
have something one of the most powerful
messages that cuts across all of the
religious traditions in one way or
another is the sense of the of the value
the gift of each individual and the the
human human dignity the the love of
neighbor with that I think somehow where
we we need to focus is on translating
these horrors and the
numbers into human faces and families
what does what does maternal mortality
mean what does child mortality mean so
of course it is the hitting people in
the face with with the enormity of the
problems and it's poignancy and
appealing to people's hearts but I think
it has to come with this sense of hope
that that these are problems that can be
overcome that have been overcome in many
places that we've overcome them in this
country and then of course some we're
tailing at the end is the fear factor
that if we don't there is no world for
our children and grandchildren because
there is no no safety you know in a
divided world where people are angry and
unjust so we're balancing this sense of
humanity the the sense of hope the sense
of conscience that comes from from being
part of a family and then somewhere we
we need to convey this sense that it is
not a viable sustainable safe world
unless we are able to work for justice
and development unless people have jobs
go to school and have hope Thank You
Catherine I appreciate what you and
others have said in writing and in your
words to encourage us that yes this is a
new day and we can see the progress made
on the Millennium Development Goals and
so we can have hope this is not hopeless
Melinda um I wanted to maybe end with a
site on hope hopeful side as well on the
and on the political side I mean I was
pretty harsh about that perhaps earlier
but I had a meeting with the new chair
of the House Financial Services
Committee which is Spencer Bachus who is
a Republican from Birmingham Alabama
with a dozen faith leaders from
Birmingham
had a meeting with him and he has been a
stalwart champion of debt relief
initiatives because the faith committee
community in Birmingham reached out to
him and you know 1999 David Beckman was
very involved in that as well and and so
we were strategizing with him you know I
did say I know that this is a different
fiscal environment this is a challenging
time and and he said it is challenging
but we can make the argument so they can
hear them he said because it is very
it's so much more efficient and
effective dollar for dollar to be doing
this type of foreign assistance than
sending our military when there's
instability and so forth so he really
strongly feels like we can make that
national security argument is and and
and I think it's important to educate as
ambassador Hall said the new members and
one of the things he suggested to us is
really most of the new members of
Congress are you know are connected to
faith communities there's a large
percentage of them that are Catholic he
pointed out and that he said get to them
with members of the faith community in
their districts and really start to make
this argument now so there isn't a
knee-jerk reaction against it as we move
forward new legislation for debt relief
and so forth so I so I want to come you
know kind of commend us to do that
education work and that the getting the
faith community involved through the
through faith leaders initiatives as
well as getting congregations involved
we have congregations programs that
bread for the world also does to get
congregations educated on these issues
to move some of the new members Thank
You Melinda we are going to close with
Dean Harry Attridge but before so you
don't get the last word but the second
to last word David Melissa talked about
chairman Spencer Bachus I've got to tell
you that he got involved in poverty
issues thanks to really two of his
constituents in Birmingham
lady named Pat Pelham and her friend
Elaine Van Cleave this was back in the
late 90s and Pat was a young mother who
in her prayers one morning felt
compelled to do something about Africa
and her minister suggested that she get
her church involved in bread for the
world she did that in a tremendously
effective way began to engage
representative back as he's uh he's now
a close friend actually and you know
he's very candid that he never thought
about Africa in his life but patni lane
and other friends constituents in
Birmingham drew him into the issue when
the Jubilee campaign really got started
in 1999 he was in a key position they
came to Washington to see him they
talked about at that time I think it was
30,000 kids who are dying every day from
preventable causes they talked about
that that gripped his heart he became
the most effective advocate in the US
has over the years the most effective
advocate for debt relief in the US
Congress he's worked on primary
education in Africa and around the world
he voted for the child nutrition act
that came before Congress dealing with
nutrition programs in this country in
December he's really got a heart for
these things but it really started with
constituents who with Pat Pelham
listening to God's call to her and using
the power that we have as people who
live in this country to change history
for poor people and I'm also quite
hopeful I the world's made progress
against poverty over the last ten years
in fact voter public attitudes toward
poor people in our country around the
world had become more supportive of
government efforts
to reduce poverty I think we have a real
chance right now in the midst of the
recession to get our country and its
government to get more serious about
poverty than we have ever been and that
that's what God's calling us to do this
land no question thank you David Dean
Harold attridge also professor of New
Testament at Yale Divinity School it's
clear as this panel and presentation
tonight have indicated that the
Christian faith indicates that we have
an obligation an obligation to feed the
hungry to give drink to the thirsty to
clothe the naked to shelter the homeless
indeed our ultimate relationship with
our creator and Redeemer depends on how
we take that obligation Jewish and
Christian brothers and sisters have
similar ways of framing the obligation
that comes from religious faith for us
Christians and lent is a time to reflect
to reflect to get sharper focus and to
engage in action as congressman [ __ ]
said I join congressman senator Coons
and the panel here tonight in calling on
all our alums all our friends and all
people of faith in this country to
engage during this time of Lent in a
period of reflection reflection on not
simply personal sin but on the social
sin that is poverty reflection not
simply on the fact of that sin but also
when its causes and the ways in which it
can be dealt with and then I call upon
us all to act to act by giving giving
generously to act by connecting with all
of the organizations or at least some of
the organizations represented here
tonight who are engaged in the the war
on poverty and finally to engage in
vigorous public discourse about what our
obligations are as a nation to deal with
the reality of poverty yale divinity
school stands ready to help that
conversation move forward during the
course of the next 40 days through our
website through facebook and through
twitter all sorts of interesting new
media will be engaging in highlighting
best practices and highlighting what's
being done by our friends and
our partners in this whole effort so I
invite you to sign up for facebook and
join us in that brave new electronic
world while you're doing so let's all
also give thanks to those who've made
this program possible tonight to Senator
Coons and to our distinguished panel to
reverent later for giving the leadership
on this panel tonight and to all of the
staff of the international relief and
development agency and Yale Divinity
School who pull this panel together
thank you one and all for being here
with us tonight and thank you